é uma honra estar aqui falando pra vocês
sobre um tema que diz respeito a todo
mundo não é só meu é de todos é um
assunto muito transversal que é a
acessibilidade que é inclusão social a
primeiramente ao chegar aqui nesse
auditório eu tive que encarar barreiras
e fazendo um paralelo ao vídeo que eu
vou apresentar agora daqui a pouquinho
eu quero falar que nem sempre é
confortável ou é uma opção popular né
é quase irresistível para qualquer um de
vocês pular até mesmo nos anúncios no
youtube popular anúncio é irresistível é
tentador mas para mim popular nem sempre
é uma opção então não tinha não tem
nenhuma rampa ao redor talvez tenha uma
longa distância um raio muito grande
aqui então quero dizer que essas
barreiras muito perceptíveis né físicas
elas impedem muito a vida de uma pessoa
que precisa de acesso
o projeto mulher inacessível que são as
cidades mulher inacessível são as
cidades nasceu num café em são paulo e
um amigo jornalista então disse que
aquelas idéias e aquela experiência de
vida àquela aquelas vivências tinham que
se tornar mais abrangentes e eu estava
no meio de uma gestão do município de
vitória a onde atuei pouco oito anos um
pouco mais de oito anos a é na
coordenação das políticas públicas nessa
área é um papel muito de articuladora
depois fui descobrindo que mais que a
administradora eu era uma articuladora
aí enfim é um trabalho muito difícil
muito árduo mas que hoje me rendem um
pouco de benefícios como em algumas
calçadas poder transitar com mais
autonomia poder pegar um ônibus coletivo
porque não tem só um já tem
da frota né então isso faz parte das
políticas públicas
então essa idéia nasceu nesse sentido
das vivências e das das falas dos
relatos e ele isso tem que se tornar
mais abrangente ea gente teve essa idéia
foi dele o nome também foi dele né
mulher inacessível ea partir de então a
gente conseguiu essa página e o projeto
cresceu em um piscar de olhos uma
mudança de atitude é sim o tema do
evento ou se usar outro olhar tem tudo a
ver porque muitas vezes a gente não
amplia essa visão e acaba virando uma
direção só deixando de perceber muitas
outras coisas que acontecem na periferia
do olhar né
a dádiva de conviver com as diferenças
pode ser uma delas
[Música]
o
o mundo
[Música]
pois bem a então quando a gente fala que
o lar nem sempre é uma opção
antes de partir pra esse número que lá
atrás a gente fala sobre usar periferia
do olhar que a gente não vê não percebe
né esses 46 milhões de pessoas com
deficiência no brasil mas a partir de
agora eu tenho certeza que essa reflexão
esse olhar será diferente para cada um
de vocês
no brasil temos 45 milhões de pessoas
com algum tipo de deficiência e isso
representa aproximadamente 24% da
população
onde estão essas pessoas estão nessa
periferia do olhar que a gente não
exercita no dia a dia
daí essa invisibilidade gera condições
equivocadas de adaptação por exemplo uma
rampa que a pessoa com deficiência não
têm autonomia e nem independência e nem
segurança ela foge dos requisitos de
acessibilidade
então pra quê
uma rampa no palco do auditório um
cadeirante nunca vai palestrar
ele não aparece ele não vem aqui essa é
uma visão muito ruim e que só reforça o
preconceito a discriminação
bom essa é a acessibilidade mais
perceptível que todos nós sabemos ou que
temos uma noção ou que quando projetamos
alguma coisa logo vamos pensar na rampa
banheiros elevadores mas a
acessibilidade elas não se restringe ou
se é resume só à acessibilidade
arquitetônica afinal de contas um cego
por exemplo não vai ter uma necessidade
de uma rampa mas vai ter necessidade de
informação e acaba de cometer uma gafe
quando na
minha apresentação eu não faço uma
pergunta educada civilizada existe na
platéia alguma pessoa com deficiência
visual ou cega que levante a mão
pois aí me permite ler os slides e na
hora do vídeo eu vou eu vou precisar
descrever as imagens pra você do vídeo
que foi sobre pular o anúncio no youtube
que mostra uma barreira na frente de uma
pessoa com cadeira de rodas para fazer
essa relação que é impossível você pular
aquela barreira no caso foi um monte de
britas de pedras e um cadeirante está
indo em direção e se depara com aquela
barreira física e aí ele não consegue
seguir adiante
esse foi o vídeo que a gente apresentou
a e agora nesse slide
eu estou apresentando os diversos tipos
de acessibilidade uma sociedade
inclusiva tem que promover a
acessibilidade no sistema geral é da
sociedade no caso né e então a gente
falou de acessibilidade arquitetônica
que é mais a mariana precisa e
acessibilidade atitudinal maior do que
aquelas britas que estavam no vídeo essa
é a nossa maior barreira eu sei que essa
rampa está inadequada ela não não está
dentro da norma técnica 9050 da abnt
mas eu não mudo ela fica aí essa
barreira atitudinal ela é a maior de
todas no nosso cotidiano a
comunicacional que é essa que eu acabei
de falar de promover informação para
quem tem algum tipo de deficiência
visual e até mesmo o motora é você
transformar em palavras aquilo tudo que
está a imagem é quando vocês estão
assistindo alguma algum filme alguma
programação vem um barulhinho pampa e é
escrito áudio descrição que aquela
programação ainda não são todas
infelizmente tem o
o usb unidade de informação onde todas
as imagens estão descritas
áudio-descrição assim como diversas
outras legislações né ela é uma lei e
todos os canais têm que ter na sua grade
de programação
há o critério de acessibilidade digital
é de informação que é áudio descrição ea
libras que a gente vê também e muitos e
muitas situações porém nem todas na
abertura da copa
faltou lá o itep de libras os surdos
ficaram de fora
acessibilidade metodológica que é o
método que eu vou utilizar para aquele
aluno pra aquela pessoa que está ali no
meu grupo possa ter acesso aquilo que eu
tô ensinando enfim passando a
instrumental qual é o instrumento que eu
vou utilizar ea programática que é no
nas leis né nos projetos que a pessoa
possa ter é acesso a essas informações
e você incluir em seu projeto todas as
pessoas a uma outra coisa é ser
acessível e será adaptado o movimento
das pessoas com deficiência ele não é
tão antigo assim ele é um pouco novo
então vem aí de 40 anos 40 e poucos anos
e algumas seleções vieram depois algumas
construções vieram depois
e que ocasionará até hoje na adaptação
mas aqueles ambientes que são projetados
já há novos eles já são acessíveis
então uma coisa ser acessível outra
coisa ser adaptado
agora adaptação também precisa seguir as
normas técnicas não é porque o pedreiro
técnico eles quiseram fazer daquela
maneira e enfim como nós não temos o
hábito de ler manuais
falhamos muitas vezes está lá escrito de
como fazer o grau da rampa
tudo tudo isso vem se transformando e
mudando assim como conceitos e valor
cores mudam numa sociedade e isso não
não é diferente né as empresas inclusive
o mercado de trabalho vem se ajustando à
legislação algumas empresas têm
acessibilidade com valor e outras apenas
para cumprir a legislação
então é isso a ter acessibilidade terá
acesso você permite que a pessoa tenha
mais independência e e independência o
favor não me dê licença ela não exige
permissão e por menos preconceito atinge
aquela acessibilidade digital que é no
qual o futuro eu falei é o o que mais
impede que a gente se desenvolva
plenamente numa sociedade é essa
barreira atitudinal é o preconceito é
muito ruim porque quando você não sabe
não não se informou não conhece não
convive esse preconceito ele aumenta
então se as pessoas com deficiência que
liz 46 milhões tiverem oportunidades
é como todas as pessoas nascem
deficiência melhor será o convívio
porque é convivendo que se aprende cada
um é diferente na sua diversidade sua
especificidade eu sou uma pessoa com
deficiência diferente de outra pessoa
com deficiência com a mesma deficiência
então cada um então conviver vai dar
todas as respostas às vagas por exemplo
é reservada para as pessoas com
deficiência não são de vocês sem
deficiência nem por cinco minutos
há uma cultura que precisa ser também
construída às pessoas com deficiência
dirigem vivem elas batalhão elas
trabalham elas casam elas namoram elas
vivem a vida cotidiana como qualquer
outra pessoa então se aquela vaga está
lá é porque ela vai ser utilizada e no
momento em que você estaciona naquela
vaga você permite
e que diversas situações difíceis e até
cruéis para dizer o mínimo com a pessoa
com deficiência uma reunião uma
entrevista de emprego uma consulta
médica e tal que ela vai perder em
função da sua falta de civilidade
então é todas as pessoas elas têm sonhos
né e quando a gente tem essa capacidade
de de também vivenciar e também
oportunidades
todos nós vamos um dia é realizar os
sonhos e você terá acessibilidade em
todas as os sistemas gerais da sociedade
é um sonho é muito bom que eu não tenho
que pensar
ao sair de casa nas barreiras que eu vou
enfrentar
eu digo as barreiras físicas porque
outras barreiras podem surgir na vida de
qualquer um mas sobretudo na minha além
das outras que podem surgir como na vida
de qualquer um eu tenho que pensar se é
naquele toalete eu vou conseguir entrar
se lá naquele espaço e vou conseguir
chegar porque hoje é assim se tem um
espaço acessível e outro não acessível
eu vou escolher aquele que é porque
aquelas aqueles ambientes que não são
acessíveis
eu vou deixar de lado e isso mostra que
não é tão desenvolvido assim a uma coisa
importante é representar esses 46
milhões de pessoas com deficiência no
brasil porque hoje 3 de dezembro no dia
mundial
o dia internacional dos direitos da
pessoa com deficiência
bom então assim o mundo inteiro rende
homenagens pela passagem do nosso dia
é então se há muito o que se comemorar
como por exemplo a convenção
internacional dos direitos da pessoa com
deficiência que é o maior instrumento
legal que temos na área é que inclusive
define o que é deficiência traz essa
abordagem da traz essa abordagem atual
de deficiência em que o ambiente
limita a minha deficiência não o
ambiente me torna é o ambiente diz você
tem uma deficiência então é hoje é o dia
internacional dos direitos da pessoa com
deficiência e esse é um marco para se
comemorar essa convenção mas também há o
que se lamentar que são as cicatrizes
deixadas pela exclusão pela pelo
isolamento e pelo preconceito difíceis
de cicatrizar e isso é de estrutura a
força do movimento pelo brasil afora
então o pessoal tem uma coisa que quero
dizer pra vocês é a informação é tudo
ela que vai desbravar
é ela que vai nos tornar capazes de
realizar ações é ela que vai diminuir
que vai eliminar aquela barreira
atitudinal então o pessoal
a atitude é fundamental se você deseja
realizar algo você arruma meios de fazê
los se você não deseja você arruma
desculpas então muito obrigado a todos
até a próxima
[Aplausos]